the disaster artist is directed by James
Franco and stars him as Tommy Wiseau
the director writer star producer of the
room one of the worst films ever made
what makes you say though hey Tommy how
you doing
wow I've been better what's new with you
I'm just working on my review of the
disaster artist if you wouldn't mind I
just need a little privacy Wow this film
is based off the book by Greg Sestero
who played mark in the original film and
it's all about the making of the room
how Greg and Tommy became friends
beforehand the dream they both shared of
wanting to get into Hollywood Greg as an
actor and Tommy as a actor slash
director and when nothing was really
working out for them they decided well
let's just make this on our own Tommy
seemingly has a bottomless pit of money
and so where's the money coming from who
knows but they decide to make a movie
and of course as all of you know it
doesn't really go that well the first
time I saw the room was on Adult Swim
they aired it as an April Fool's joke
one year and I remember thinking what
the hell is this what is going on I came
there for I think home movies or
whatever show was on at the time
and I was greeted with this and I
thought to myself well this definitely
needs to be researched and as you guys
know it became a huge cult favorite
midnight screenings people throwing
spoons at the screen whenever spoon
memorabilia showed up in the background
and it was also my very first hilarious
'ti review that I ever filmed it's not
true I did not hit her I did
not
oh yeah thanks man
so I never really thought I would see a
real big Hollywood movie made about the
room I always thought it would just be
this little cult thing that myself and
other film fans appreciated but here we
are
gratefully this movie is fantastic
this is a very very inspiring movie
surprisingly a lot of people look at
Tommy Wiseau and his creation and laugh
this guy included but there's something
about it that's special there's
something about it that has captured the
hearts of a lot of people it's not just
about you attacking me upon Lisa and all
that stuff like that's definitely that's
definitely a big part of it but there's
something really heartfelt about the
creation of the room and that's
something a disaster artist nailed the
fact that it's actually kind of
inspiring that these two guys with
really nothing to their name except this
bottomless pit of money that Tommy
seemingly has created something that has
become endearing in film culture
probably not in the way they expected it
to but the film does a good job of
exploring that side of it as well the
reaction to the room and how Tommy had
to kind of change his outlook on things
because I'm sure has a lot of you know
at first it was this very dark
Tennessee Williams thing and eventually
no as a black comedy it's all black
black comedy you laugh you have fun just
don't know yourself I'm guy haha is that
pretty good thanks man
it means a lot coming from you James
Franco is incredible as wise Oh the
opening sequence where were introduced
to him in an acting class the
anticipation is so real they do such a
great job of introducing this
larger-than-life person and throughout
the entire film
he's mesmerizing to watch he is so so
funny in this film and he captures
something that was pretty difficult I
imagine and something I was concerned
about going in I was afraid that it was
just going to be like hey remember all
of those funny moments from the room
that you laugh at oh hi mark and all
those lines that are so hilarious I was
hoping it wasn't just going to be like
hey isn't that funny yeah it's it's kind
of funny let's all laugh at it this
movie did a great job of showing the
endearing loving side of Tommy the human
as best as we can comprehend who he hits
this film did
great job of not laughing at him in fact
and I don't consider this a spoiler
because it's a true story and everyone
knows that the room was not intended to
be as funny as it was when Tommy is
slowly realizing the way people are
reacting to his movie it was
heartbreaking I really felt for him so
the film did a good job of not just
laughing at the room it has moments for
all of us room fans who have watched
this movie multiple times that we are
going to really love and appreciate and
jokes that we're going to get that
others may not you've never heard of or
seen the room but for everyone else it's
sort of an IDI would like story this
endearing man who is not the greatest at
what he does and has a really strange
work around of getting to what he wants
but you can at least respect him for
being so inspired to want to follow his
dreams no matter what anyone told him
Tommy Wiseau is one of the most
mysterious figures in the filmmaking
industry no one knows anything about him
he won't explain anything whenever
someone asks him questions this movie
did the best job they could have at
peeling back those layers and seeing
what's behind the curtain
and trying to present a human being
because he's one of the most eccentric
people you could ever meet and that
makes the fact that this story becomes
so relatable in the end all the more
impressive they also did an incredible
job at recreating sequences in the room
right down to the framing of some shots
there's the sequence on the rooftop in
the movie where Denny and Lisa and
Lisa's mom are arguing about where Denny
gets the drugs from you're not my
mother that scene they recreated
it perfectly how in the original film
the framing is so off it begins to cut
off Lisa's head they just got everything
right Franco clearly has a passion for
this story and dave Franco his brother
is very good as Gregg Seth Rogen is also
really good in the movie all the
performances are pretty strong but my
one flaw with the movie I would say is
that a few characters like Josh
Hutcherson who portrays the character of
Denny some of them are just sort of like
famous people who are in the film and
they don't really have much of anything
to do their characters are very very one
and this could be because not much is
known about them perhaps not I'm not
positive on that but it would have been
nice if some of the background
supporting characters got a little more
attention like the way Greg and Tommy's
character did the disaster artists is an
extremely funny and endearing movie
about the making of a movie that didn't
go quite as planned and I had a great
time with it I'm gonna give the disaster
artist and a minus y mano why not give
applause well I said I had just a couple
little you know flaws with it and stuff
well you said mo there's so god why not
give applause well you don't have to
give a movie your highest grade just
because you didn't have that many flaws
with it I mean like a grade is just a
great like it's the review that matters
Tommy not the great well tell me what
grade you'll give the room huh you say
like the room where you give that
applause you don't want me to tell you
what I give the room I like it I've
watched it many times
it's it's good well one over guys thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here oh you're gonna saya come on sad
and get stuck Minh eyes
[Music]